welcome to this video the first part of
a new series about chess tactics chess
calculation yeah you notice totally
different screen what I'm doing here and
the first part of the series the series
will also face feature tactical
positions calculation exercises studies
things like that but the first thing I'm
going to do in this series is to do
something that was requested multiple
times that I should actually solve some
technical problems in real time with the
tactics trainer
there are many of those online but I'm
using here's the tactics trainer of
chess common unfortunately the screen is
other let's say the screen the state of
the actual board is relatively
relatively little I couldn't really yeah
and so no way to to to enlarge the board
so I actually try to record this and
then try to to blow up the board
afterwards a bit I hope this is an
acceptable quality okay what I'm going
to do something to solve those problems
and try to try to explain the approach
in calculation um this is the first
position that is presented to me I reset
my tactics rating so I'm so I'm starting
with the very I think with the no rating
actually um okay this is the first
position white to play and the first
thing that is apparent is that time is
time is urgent we don't have time for
for snow moves blackest attacking the
rook on you one I don't think I can do
any annotation here no I can't the rook
only one is attacked with mate we need
to be quick and we also have a couple of
pieces near the king it's always
important to determine if you attack the
King what kind what pieces are actually
involved in the attack we don't need to
look at let's
much about rook moves from the rook on
you one or something it must be about
rook on g7 Bishop on age six and the
Queen and in fact we see that Queen g7
would be checkmate
but the rook is on g7 rook g8 he can
play rook takes g8 and cover g7 but we
can take on h7 and made on g7 so my
first score is 1075 okay going to yeah I
did I got a low score 20% because I took
me eight minutes yeah I needed to set up
the recording and so on okay the next
problem Matt I don't care much about the
time that is needed
okay so we have white and computer he is
playing group 2a g8 yeah the queen is
attacked we have what is this actually
we have five pounds for the piece
interesting and our queen is attacked
young again we should probably play em
play some some some tactical or direct
continuation with the check probably how
to how to play this if I think about
Queen a5 check I see that the King only
has a couple of responses King c7
disrupt d7 check we win the Queen and
the game probably if we go queen a5
checking b8 there's rook b5 which looks
like it wins the Queen again hmm
does black have a defense only relevant
defense after b5 would be rook takes G
to check Queen takes King takes G 294
check just to check no double check but
I can take on b7 with check so Queen a5
shock shot should
this yeah King c7 that was Rupert e71 in
the Queen and now we should win the
Queen with Ruth b5 yeah just 80% took me
too long ok next problem
ok like black is playing this move yeah
what to do here yeah we see that blacks
king is in some trouble it's on f8 the
pawn is on f7 very important attacking
piece taking unit Lukas on f1 yeah we
should always think about how can we
maybe promote the pawn and here the move
Queen g8 check comes into mind
immediately rook takes pawn takes
promotes with check check from the rook
on f1 and the Queen's are double check
and if after Queen g8 you please King e7
we promote f8 so if you have those fart
one spots or well think about promotion
combinations it's there anything better
like a mate and two or something I don't
think so so this should be should be the
winner yet here we can just promote and
win this thing with two two queens um
there is probably also made but it's
enough ok next one okay we're playing us
black here Queenie - hmm okay yeah what
comes into my dear yeah pins pins are a
very important feature and chess and
here we have a pin the bishop on g4 pins
the knight to the Queen and also very
important is to recognize that there is
a pawn on g3 which weakens to the night
the night is unstable on a3 it's not
protected by a pond and the second thing
that comes to mind is that on d4 there
is a power
that is only protected by the night and
not by a pawn so if white will have a
pawn on c3 this isn't a big problem but
here we can take and just just win the
house yeah
the computer here playing the move
recaptured but otherwise we would have
won the piece as well this pin is too
much important is to note the weaknesses
in the position d4 was weak f3 was
unprotected by a pawn and this pin so
here we just just win the Queen low
score I take too long okay next next one
like computer he is taking only 6 yeah
here we we see that we can take on e6
with with with many pieces the pawn the
knight the Queen and yeah we should
examine them but Queen takes is 6 it's
the first move that really comes to mind
it gets the Queen near the King with a
check and if you have this opportunity
you should always check if this is the
right move very often it will be because
the Queen has the strongest attacking
piece should be near the King yeah here
we have a classic example of the
smothered mate Knight f7 checker night
oops sorry night
h6 check double check very important
King f8 is also made on g8 on f7 this
one mate this can be seen relatively
quickly if you know this smothered maid
motif then it's quite obvious okay
the next one we play as white yeah okay
so in this position what should be the
first thing that pops into into our mind
the pin the pin on the long diagonal
queen is on c3 black wieners on deform
the pin here means that the Queen on d4
cannot move freely and we have a great
move to to exploit that this is rook t1
it's quite quite cute the Queen takes
and now of course not the recapture it's
not mandatory to recapture immediately
we have rook takes d7 the intermediate
move or solution Duke that wins does the
rook with check
now we take on c3 and we all look up so
important the pin and noticing that rook
takes d7 is a check so we can just win
the rock okay the next one we are
playing black and a5 was played so what
are features of this position
what has the a pawn that looks dangerous
so we should probably be quick about
things not not yet lose them lose any
time we have some some pieces in the
attack both rooks doubled on the effort
and the Queen on age 5 so what are
mating motifs what mating motif here
would be look on the on h1 for example
with the rook on g2 this this could
easily happen
let's check yeah look h3 looks very
tempting for just threatening the made
on h1
yeah after Luke h3 what should do I do
it's difficult there's not only the mate
but also look h1 check King moves rook
takes a one winning the rook yeah it's
very difficult to defend I don't see a
defense rook rook h3 seems to seems to
win important to note that this rook on
g2 is not very helpful it just allows
this made on h1 so this this should be
right yeah
what should why do there's this mate and
if you if you go to FY cannot move the
pieces if you go to f1 does check on h1
look G 1 this actually showed it
directly winning or not Queen h3 check
kingi to a queen a 3-1 okay that's it's
a bit I can or not I cannot really
really move the pieces he unfortunately
ok the next one we are playing this
black like Knight f3
yeah there are pins all over the place
but then hmm it's equal material right
one big thing is our rook on the edge is
protected so I can just take the Queen
right and then take d3 that was a bit
easy so black has just just wanted peace
okay next one yeah Queen Queen took on
e4 is the is the move yeah okay here the
Queen on e4 is only protected by the
night and with Bishop takes c3 we can
take off this night and just any piece
easy I guess I need some some some some
harder problems okay yeah here white
legs rook F 1 so we can take F 1 with
both rooks
rook e1 takes as possible or look F 1 as
possible it's important to note the pin
on the long diagonal so after any
capture there's only Queen g1 as an
intermediate move not a Tamia move as an
interposing move that does something
about the check if we take with the
iroko have a queen g1 and we take it
we're not winning immediately but if we
take with their frog there's only queen
g1 and made next yeah the problem is I
only get very little scores because and
therefore the problems are not getting
getting much more difficult next one
hmm
hook everyone check wait
the best rate for that is only sixty
percent forty percent didn't see the
maid that's weird
okay the next one K King to ji-sun yeah
white white to move and it's about the
pants yeah
why should try to promote the pawns hmm
look up look at checks first this is
always a good idea here h6 check comes
into mind with h6 check black cannot
take the night a Jade Queen promotes so
this is this is the winner and we get a
new queen if you would have gone to h8
there's rook c8 with a checkmate next
and we win just 13 points ok next
problem
black black toons
yeah blacks King listen in some trouble
here but how do we how do we actually
actually meet him
yeah the first ideas Bishop g5 check
after that the King really only can go
to Iran and then we take the rook I
don't know is there something better I
don't think so so let's just let's just
grab everything and now let's first
check it's there better move then then
taking the rook we give the check here
again you can go to D - I don't see a
maid
I just just grab this rope and continue
from here yeah this is this is this
Valley - I made sooner or later Bishop
III probably with Queen g1 mate or queen
F - mate oh no sorry can he can take ya
then not in this one okay just 21 points
okay next one take some time to get to
get to a higher rating here yeah this we
have before the smothered mate easy to
see with the double check and that's it
21 points
okay going to be six
yeah here we have a typical position
like is attacking with all heavy pieces
and he will be able to deliver checkmate
just by a serious by a series of checks
rook takes you to must be right in this
position it is right okay
the way to MIT I cannot really put it on
the board here right after King takes
this rook g4 check King at SRI Queen f3
check King edge to rook takes h4 Andrew
catch one mate there is too much
attacking power here cook team takes two
to queen g4 check but probably also in
check King edge to Queen takes h4
kingi 225 checking f3 queen erotic yeah
it's also made Roxy for us just a bit
quicker okay and the next one I think
it's it's quite funny that they have
made in one here double check mate still
only 60% of people manage that I don't
know
yeah made in one the only the only made
in one right double checks always look
for double checks they have pretty
difficult to defend okay yeah black
crept on one c3 very greedy move and
here we have a typical situation we can
take on c3 and Bishop h7 very typical
motif winning the Queen
a three okay yeah our night a subject
but so we not they're not forced to
immediately move this piece we should
also consider consider other things in
this in this particular situation it is
clear that the dark squares I enormous
ly weakened age for g3 III why this
lacking is dark squared bishop the
mousse that comes to mind she is Queen
takes e5 Queen takes e5 a before Bishop
III should should win the house
queenie v de v rook takes d2 rook takes
t2 Bishop e3 check King moves Bishop d2
and where piece up and attacking the c1
R okay this will is a piece so let's
check Queenie five d5 rook d2a before
then we at least have Bishop takes c3
winning now 25 s right yeah and Bishop
d2 next and blackest is a piece up just
six points okay next one okay
yeah white white to move in this
position
yeah very dramatic position its what
tell you it's not
we are nothing really pawn down it's not
too bad
but okay it's about about the tech of
course we should always check the very
very forcing moves checks and captures
and here if we start to do that we see
that we have some pieces and detect the
Queen at the bishop if we look at the
forcing moves we will see this move at
some point made just made into always
look at checks and captures and heads
both both at the same time okay next one
maybe I can get to 1500 at least okay
Knight to f7 oh this happily looks like
like a combination or tactic more like
more like an endgame okay um what should
should why do ya the pawn the pawn
should be should be promoted let's think
about this position if we go King to
King to g6 we are threatening rook c8
mate and rook takes f7 of course after
this black will give the check on e5
King f6 Knight g4 checkers does not look
like we are promoting immediately Queen
the King f6 looks easier and tending
still rook c8 if he goes Knight to d6
how are we going to to win then
yeah rook d7 should should win Knight e4
check King g6 and we have Rupert e8 next
night eh check King G 697 is still made
after rook e8
yeah very often the move that is not a
check is the right one this should be
the case here computer is not to play
again I even get supports obstructed
yeah this is this is not fair I'm doing
a video here okay so Knight d6 covering
c8 there was rock d7 and this this
should win okay okay to b5 and like to
play here yeah what we see in this
position rather quickly out white screen
is right in and blacks camp and it does
not have many squares in fact we control
the F are we control B for c5 d5 I think
if we just attack the Queen it should be
true it should be one just drop b8 I
guess okay um yeah this is actually we
can also take the night but then Queen
g5 so probably just get the Queen Hey 11
points let's see next one
okay like you like to play here Knight
d5 hmm yeah it's attacking on c7 yeah of
course we have some some pieces in the
attack as well let's see you yeah the
problem is we control F 4 F 2 sorry F
281 and we control e 2 when if we have a
check
we will win material until we can just
play Bishop die for I think yeah Bishop
e2 check is coming next and black and
blue win the Queen white can give this
check but it's not helping
King d8 and that Queen and Knight is
attacked so this is the winner so the
next one takes a 5 mm okay yeah here we
see that white has number of pieces in
the attack for 96-95 and the rook and
yeah when we start to calculate here
queen takes f5 as a move that we
definitely need to check it's very
forcing black has to recapture and then
with the G file is opened so after G
takes G takes Knight f-7s mate maiden in
one move
yeah here we can just take it 6 and King
h8 does d5 or D take survive without me
to come okay
okay Bishop c5 yeah how does how does
why doin here we have a very very strong
attack knight on f6 and Bishop on h6
blacks King us is boxed in really on h8
the only thing we need to do is to get
the Queen involved if we move the Queen
on the G file somewhere he will take the
take the knight I think there is a
simple way to do it just here queen h7
mate and he has no defense against that
can maybe take Queen takes maid next
move
Bishop to f1 okay hmm
this does not look as as obvious we
don't have a don't have an attack on the
King or anything but still whites
position looks a bit out of harmony
night on c2 in particular we should
check a checks captures attacks and here
we can attack the Queen with Knight b3
and the closer look shows this Queen has
mask we're just winning the Queen iam
okay ten points yeah this is a very well
known mating motif that this has always
been one of my favourite mates I only
recently discovered that this actually
has a name and it is associated to a
player called Bowden wardens mate
and this is the mate very nice can
easily be overlooked this is a very
typical way that is delivered really
happens in in games so something to take
note of in this situation okay the next
one let's get at least two to 1,600 or
something okay King c7 okay we should
look at checks captures as mentioned and
double checks are especially attractive
here we have two nighti a double check
and not be four half double check and if
we look at not be $5 check King c8 we
will see that looking at the next check
Knight takes a seven is very rewarding
it's a mate only nine points for that
okay next one let's see how many points
I get ever actually don't
talk I just and just play the move out
night piece and made into this is a
hundred percent score but only gives me
13 points so it's probably a long way to
to get to get get higher now I had I
reset at my school I had I had made some
some tactics and I had solved some had
two thousand something two thousand two
hundred three hundred or something but
it seems you to take a while to get this
tactic trainer to a little bit more
sophisticated positions I hope you
enjoyed it anyway I think maybe some of
you expected more difficult positions
where I have to calculate a bit more but
it's there is no other way we need to
start start literally with the score and
climb up so if I do this the next time
or when I do this the next time the
positions will be certainly more
difficult I hope you enjoyed it anyway
thanks for watching